Good morning, even the caramel greets you
with its brief information today, Tuesday
, June 29. Four people are
hospitalized after a shooting in
a neighborhood near Which Way and
Greenberg Parkway, according to
the Hang Years authorities, when the shooting
happened around seven o'clock.  thirty
at night and it was the result of a
domestic dispute the status of the
victims has not been made public
the mother accused of killing her 7-
year-old son is back in las
vegas the mind moreno rodríguez was
transferred from  colorado and is
now being held at the
clark moreno rodriguez county detention center is
accused of killing her son liam pasteur
and leaving his body on a trail
near malkin springs
the federal moratorium on evictions
from july 20 on july 31 if you  you are
among valley residents
facing the prospect of losing your
home the city of north las vegas is
hosting a community forum tonight  e
within being a daughter from four to five in
the afternoon, a resource fair is also organized
that will begin immediately
after the forum where
housing and housing experts will be
present to answer your
questions last week the government of
president joe biden extended the
moratorium a  another month and for the last time
and another diaper bank has been organized
for needy families in the valley the
organization of brawn has
scheduled another donation of diapers for
babies from 10 in the morning to 2 in the afternoon
tomorrow Wednesday at the
living recreation center  in the city of henderson applicants are being
asked to apply to the davis
bounty firework now we turn to
the weather forecast expecting a day
with sun and clouds the high will be
near 104 degrees temperatures
will begin to drop and
chances of rain and lightning return
Have a good day today I went out karam
and today I am able to give you a brief informative
for Disney in Spanish
[Music  AC]